we have a quote here if you want to read
the quote and then we'll sure the the
more successful the villain the more
successful the picture
okay any thoughts on who said that
I I don't know no okay interesting I
thought maybe
um you would know uh just because uh the
Hitchcock or something there you go okay
tell him what he's wanted okay
so uh what do you what are your thoughts
in relation to Hitchcock's films I love
Hitchcock's films
um I think you know he
uh masterfully crafts uh stories in a
way that that
celebrate uh themes and and ideas that
go beyond just the plot and the
character while also having you know
really interesting characters having
great suspense and so on in terms of the
quote I I think it's absolutely true
that the villains are really
should be the most interesting character
in a movie I think that that actually is
is the case because
if you want a good movie you need to be
able to understand the perspectives of
all the different characters so so if
there's a villain in the movie they I
mean I think a good movie The Villain is
not just like a pure force of evil it's
not just like oh there's something some
malevolent force and there's the person
fighting it who's the kind of the the
hero of it you want to be able to
understand from the perspective of the
villain they're the hero in their story
right that's that's people always say
that and I think that is really really
absolutely true and that you need as a
as a viewer
um as a Creator you know if you're
making a film you need to be able to
understand get in the mindset of every
kind of major character in the film and
understand why they're doing what
they're doing what is the purpose of
what they're doing what is their goal uh
and so on
what is your favorite Alfred Hitchcock
film so I uh I love so many of his films
I mean it's hard you know it's hard to
pick one I'm gonna I'm gonna say one
that I think is uh most underrated maybe
and that's the film stage fright
um and the reason I love that film is
because it
messes around with what your
expectations are narratively so it sort
of tells a story and you kind of find
yourself
looking at the Pres again the
perspectives of the different characters
because they're really interesting
characters I love Marlena Dietrich is
one of my favorite actors ever and she's
so good in that movie
um and I don't want to spoil exactly
what happens in it but but she's such an
interesting character in your
relationship to her uh really changes as
you go throughout the film and uh it
really is one of the rare films that you
know gets to the end I guess it has a
Twist but it's not really just just a
Twist because the many twists are are
interesting or fun but it's a Twist that
really changed my whole perspective on
the film it really flipped my entire
understanding of the film my entire
understanding of like how I related to
the characters how I empathize with the
characters
um and it I love the experience of
watching it
do you think the viewers should almost
have a hint of empathy toward the
villain to really put it over the top
absolutely yeah I think I mean I think
again the best the best films have uh
work where you can really understand the
perspective of the villain and maybe
maybe you don't agree with what they're
doing you know that I I think that might
be
a hard thing to accomplish in every film
um but yeah if if you can empathize with
them and understand why they're doing
what they're doing and even think that
they're right in some sense that there's
something about what they're doing
that's right I think that makes a really
powerful film and and
um I don't really love like superhero
films for example I'm not a big fan but
I thought the Black Panther movie was
really incredible because
um uh killmonger the villain in that the
whole time you're like you know this guy
is right it's really and I think you
know they're it's sort of a a metaphor
for the um Martin Luther King Malcolm X
like the approaches to accomplishing
what you want to you know want one sort
of using uh kind of peaceful resistance
in one maybe maybe advocating for
something that's a little more uh active
or potentially violent I know that's
that's an exaggeration for Malcolm X I
don't think he was really violent
necessarily but if you look at the two
uh characters in that
they're both correct and at the end of
the film uh you know the villain is
defeated but the hero actually learns
from the villain's perspective and
changes his own perspective and that to
me is like a really
um a successful form of Storytelling and
a successful character Arc for the hero
because the hero doesn't just Triumph
the hero in fact is is sad at the end
when the villain you know dies off and
has has absorbed some of the ideas of
the villain
um in a way that's that's kind of a
compromise of everything and that is
maybe the most productive approach to
and I think that you know that's a
really uh it's a fascinating movie I
think it's a really fascinating movie
with Hitchcock's stage fright how many
times have you watched it uh probably
four or five so I've seen some of his
other movies you know I've probably seen
rear window you know 15 times I've
probably seen North by Northwest uh 20
times but
um but stage fright is it just because
of that that story structure it just it
sticks with me it's it's less of a movie
that I maybe will some of the other
movies I might revisit more because
they're more
um
fun and immersive as an experience like
rear window I find just to be so the the
characters especially just such a fun
experience to hang out with uh with
those characters and to spend time with
them and to see the kind of like
Mischief that Grace Kelly is approaching
the whole thing with and uh so maybe you
know maybe there are different types of
experiences with Hitchcock films
um
that work in different ways how does
Alfred Hitchcock build suspense
I think one of his main strategies for
building suspense is to tell the
audience something that the characters
don't know so it's uh a lot of times
people take the other approach where
they you know nobody knows anything
right there's different kind of
strategies to it
um so Hitchcock will the example that is
always given is uh um I think it's The
Man Who Knew Too Much I can't I can't
remember for sure but there's like a
bomb under the table and um the audience
sees the bomb we know it's ticking down
you know from from one minute to zero
and the characters are just having a
little chat they have no idea what's
happening and the tension is building
because we know you know time is moving
we're watching the characters and we're
like you know we want to scream at the
at the screen you know get out of there
you know say something
um and so I think that's a really
brilliant strategy to tell the audience
something that the characters don't know
I love that
how old were you when you saw your first
Hitchcock film oh boy I think I I want
to say I saw a psycho at like
eight or nine some something like that
and how was it for you as a little boy
to see it and I thought it was scary uh
of course but um no I loved it I thought
I thought it was a fun movie to watch
and I I um
I there's something just I mean it's
such a people don't even quite realize
now how much Hitchcock use these sort of
Freudian and these kind of ideas of
perversion that are that are really tied
to like classical psychology and um you
know I think uh it's easy to respond to
those ideas that they're serving grained
in society in a way that we respond
quickly to them even little kids I think
can respond quickly to them that's that
maybe speaks to some of his successes I
don't know if some of those things would
work now as we've evolved a little bit
we view psychological ideas differently
you know in the in the modern
um so I wonder if you know if kids now
if an eight-year-old now watched uh
psycho they'd probably just be like this
is boring and it's in black and white
what's going on
well he had his own issues that he dealt
with and I think it came out on screen
but in many fascinating ways yeah
absolutely so why do you think his work
will stand the test of time even even
maybe okay maybe not an eight-year-old
today but as a a would-be auteur in film
school yeah I mean I think his films are
just they they just have so many aspects
that work I mean not not every film is
great but I would say of unbelievable
percentage of his films are great and um
you know he had great casts he found
great actors to to do what he wanted and
he wasn't particularly fond of actors I
think you know if you hear quotes from
him talking about actors he sort of
viewed them as puppets and he's like why
do I have to deal with these these
people I just just say the line stand in
the place do the thing he didn't I don't
think he really liked directing actors
but he hired incredible people who were
able to to convey those stories and he
was he I think his his the best his best
skill was picking stories I think he he
chose you know short stories he chose uh
novels and other things to it to adapt
or have somebody adapt
um and I think he was just brilliant at
choosing those stories that would work
in in a film context
it was sort of like a British version of
maybe uh Rod Serling yeah absolutely
same kind of idea where it's like you
know he's taking from great source
material
um and again bringing in great actors
and you know presenting stories in a way
that I think connect with people and I
think yeah Twilight Zone I mean I think
I think it's still I it's hard for me to
judge it objectively but when I watch
you know old Twilight Zone it's it still
all really works for me and when I watch
new Twilight Zone it's the stories
aren't that good you know then they're
not they're not the same kind of
sourcing that I think was done at that
time
um and I think people don't realize how
important the source material is to the
success of those stories
do you think it has anything to do with
the pacing
yeah I mean I think uh there's there's
something about Hitchcock where he
Revels in the moment he he takes his
time and lets the uh lets the moments
sit in many places and I think that
really is it only works because of great
actors and and uh is excellent
cinematography you know excellent
structure but I think really the actors
are what hold it together they're so
compelling and Charming
um that I think you're willing to sit
with them you you want like a rear
window I love I love the movie but I
would just if you if you gave me a eight
hour movie just hanging out with the
Jimmy Stewart and Grace Kelly I would
watch that I would love that you know
that would be fun for me
um so I think you know to be able to
create an environment like that and have
a cast like that and then to tell a
story you know on top of that using
using that cast is just uh an amazing
way to kind of build out and structure a
movie